In the home stretch.
Problem 14.
If n and p are integers greater
than 1-- I didn't
write that they're integers--
and if p is a factor of both n
plus 3 and n plus 10, what
is the value of p?
So n and p are integers greater
than 1 and p is a
factor of both n plus
3 and n plus 10.
This is interesting.
So that means that n plus 3 is
equal to some number times p,
where k is just some
random number.
And we also know that n plus
10 is also equal to some--
maybe, probably, definitely
some other number times p.
And so we could subtract
3 from both
sides in this equation.
We'd get n is equal to k
times p, some number
times p minus 3.
And we also could do it here.
We can subtract 10
from both sides.
We say n is equal to some other
number times p minus 10.
And I don't know where
this is going.
I'm just really playing
around with this.
So let's see.
So both of these things
are equal to n.
What are we trying
to solve for?
We're trying to solve for p.
So some number times p minus 3
is equal to some other number
times p minus 10.
Let me see where that gets me.
So kp minus 3 is equal to
m times p minus 10.
Let's add 10 to both sides
of this equation.
You'll get kp plus 7 is
equal to m times p.
Now, this is interesting.
So if I multiply some integer
times p, right?
So this is some multiple
of p, right?
This is actually n plus 3.
But if I have some multiple of
p right here and I add 7 to
it, I get another
multiple of p.
So that means that 7 has
to be divisible by p.
There are only two numbers
that 7 is divisible by.
1 and 7.
And it's not going to be 1,
because it tells us that n and
p are both greater
than 1, right?
So p has to be 7.
p is equal to 7, which
is choice B.
And so the way I think about it
is just when you add 10 to
a number-- think
of it this way.
Ignore this whole n plus 3.
Let's just say n plus 3, let's
just say that we'll
call this Q, right?
We're saying p is a factor
of Q, right?
And then if Q is n plus 3, then
this would be Q plus 7.
I hope I'm not confusing you.
So this is divisible by p.
And then when you add 7 to it,
it's also divisible by p.
So p has to be 7, because when
I add 7 to-- think of it this
way: if n plus 3 was-- let's
say this was 21.
Not n, n plus 3 was 21, then
n would be what, 18?
n is 18, n plus 3 is 21, and
n plus 10 would be 28.
And these are both
divisible by 7.
So that's another way
you could do it.
You could actually just
try out the numbers.
But hopefully, that'll give
you the intuition.
But the big clue is some
multiple times p plus 7 is
equal to another multiple
times p.
So we know that p has to be 7
because p has to be divisible
into 7 and greater than 1.
And there's only one number
that's greater than 1 and that
is a factor of 7.
And that's B.
Or that's 7, sorry.
Next problem.
That was tricky, I think.
Problem 15.
In the queue shown above,
points A, B and C are
midpoints of the three edges.
Which of the following angles
has the least measure?
Oh man, this is going to
be a lot of drawing.
This might take the whole
time, but I'll
try my best. OK.
B, C and E.
I'm going to draw it big
just so-- actually, I'm
drawing it too big.
I'll do it the best I can.
OK.
And then they have these dotted
lines in the back.
OK, now they have--
let me draw this
in a different color.
This is point x.
This is point y.
They draw a bunch of points.
B, C, and E are the midpoints.
So this is point B.
This is point A.
This is point C.
Point D.
Point E.
And everything they drew
essentially starts at x, goes
to one of these points, and then
goes back to y, right?
It goes from x to B
to y, x to A to y.
All the choices go to each
of these points and
then go back to y.
And what they want to
know is, which angle
has the least measure?
So the way we could think about
this is, all of these
angles-- we could just draw this
part-- sorry, if this was
x, this is one of the messier
things I've ever drawn, this
is y and then the other angles,
you know it's going to
go to some point and
then come back.
And what we want to know
is, when do we
get the least angle?
Think of it this way, the longer
this base angle is, the
longer this is, the
smaller the angle.
Because this is the angle
we're measuring.
So we want to make
this angle, this
length as long as possible.
The length from whatever letter
we are to y, right?
So B to y is very short,
so this angle
would be pretty big.
A to y is even bigger.
C to y is even bigger
than that.
D to y is actually the biggest.
This is the biggest
distance, right?
So this will be the
smallest angle.
So that's ydx or xdy,
so that's choice D.
And remember, the underlying
intuition is, if I were to--
let me do the colors so you know
what I'm saying-- this
line, if I were to draw that,
that would be here.
I'm saying that corresponds
to that right there.
That's x.
That's y.
And then we're taking a
point from x to one of
these points, right?
xby, xay, xcy, and whatever
point it is, the way we get
the smallest angle is
if we make this
line as long as possible.
And you can visualize that.
Take this point further and
further out and this angle
gets smaller and smaller
and smaller.
So if you look at it that way,
what is going to be the
longest distance y to which
of these points?
y to C is the same as y to E.
y to B is very short.
y to A id a little longer.
y to C is a little longer.
y to D is the longest
distance.
So the least angle will be,
if this point is D, xdy.
And that's choice D.
Let me see if I can squeeze
problem 16 in here.
Otherwise, I'll do it
in the next video.
Problem 16.
if xy is equal to 7, x minus y
is equal to 5 then x squared y
minus xy squared is
equal to what?
All right, so we know what
xy is and we know
what x minus y is.
So let's watch this.
Factor an x out of here.
You get the same thing as x
times xy, minus-- let's factor
a y out of here.
This is the same thing
as y times xy, right?
All I did is I factored
a y out.
And now let's factor
the x minus y out.
This is the same thing as xy
times x minus y, right?
I'm just factoring the xy out.
You could do it in reverse.
You can distribute the xy and
you'd get this up here.
And this equals what?
xy is 7.
And x minus y, it gives
us right there, is 5.
7 times 5 is 35.
That's choice D.
And we are done with Test 7.
I will see you in Test 8.